hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus cross and Invitational this is
game 3 again Magnus with the white
pieces the result is 1 1 so one victory
each and we are going to have a
repetition of the line they played in
the first game
however hakarl will decide against that
Bishop the b7 line so we're not gonna
discuss all that much Magnus with the
white pieces d4 Knight f6 same as in
Game one
we have c4 e6 sorry about that
we have Knight f3 and d5 so again Queens
gambit declined on the board Knight c3
Bishop e7 and again Magnus goes for this
Bishop to f4 line we have castles and
III preparing to develop the light
square Bishop Knight b b7 and c5 same as
in game 1
c6 preparing b6 and of course h3
everything the same as in game 1 we have
b 6 b 4 a 5 and a 3 and now h6 so still
everything the same as in game 1 Bishop
to d3 and here we mentioned it to
Nakamura had already this game with the
white pieces against Apollo where he
went
Bishop to e6 but now he goes Bishop to
b7 but here he didn't like that
Bishop to b7 is not a mistake or
anything the engine very much likes the
idea but he was left with that sad their
ship in game 1 so instead he decides for
Bishop d6 which is pretty much what
everyone plays in this position so
Magnus castles and now Queen to c8
we have Queen to c2 preparing well now
connecting rooks and the bishop captures
and e3 now that the Queen was developed
so you may quite lose the temple but a
queen captures on d3 and now Queen to b7
black also develops the Queen connects
the rooks and now there is again we can
transpose into the nakamora the power of
game after Knight to e2 but here we have
Queen to c2 back by Magnus and it is as
a move 15 now that we have a completely
new game so if the C file opens up and
maybe you can put some rocks in the sea
found maybe you can do some damage to
that c6 pawn but look F to c8 Nakamura
he immediately defends it that place is
the rockin c8 we have rook if the be one
now by Magnus goes after well it puts
the rock
the same file as the Queen and now
Nakamura trades a capture son b48
captures and now again Bishop to b8 with
the same maneuver as in the game one
wanting to go Bishop to c7 to trade of
course in the dark square bishop
so Queen to see one now Magnus wants to
he wants to trade a pair of rooks and
then put the other look to a one so he
wants the Queen from c1 to defended the
rook on a one Bishop to c7 and now
Magnus trades with captures captures
that's not a captures story captures
captures and now captures on c7 Queen
captures and look to a one now offering
to trade off the other pair of Brooks as
well
we have Quinta b7 and now rook to a3
with the idea of doubling up with Queen
to a-1 so nice to eat by Hikaru he wants
to shift the night over to c7 and then
from there maybe to the Queen side but
also you you kind of want to play f6 if
everything gets traded off so you don't
allow this Knight any any ideas here
well okay not g5 obviously buddy five so
tonight the e2 by Magnus and now rook
captures on a three we have Queen
captures and night the c7 now now Hikaru
is ready to offer a queen trade with
with Queen a six or a eight nights the
f4 by Magnus and now Queen to a6
offering a queen trade we have Queen
captures and Knight captures now
attacking the b4 pawn and not night to
d3 magnet just defended so here we have
all of these nights in in a pretty much
a closed-end game so obviously we are
going to have a lot of horsing around
so f6 taking away the e5 square from
Carlson's knights and now Knight back to
d2
we have King to f7 he car starts
bringing the King into the game and the
Magnus will do the same but first f4
grabbing more control of the e5 square
we have knight back the c7 not shifting
the night over to b5 and came to f2 we
have night the b5 end and now King to f3
we have Knight to c3 and now comes g4 so
nicely just just pushing with g5 by
Hikaru and now f5
pretty much
hikaru push the pawn so he does with E 5
and now he for his the threat and of
course Magnus not interested in in
trading here so he goes back night the
c1 and Hikaru continues advancing with E
for check King back to f2 by Magnus and
now King to East 7 so now the King side
is completely blocked off the center is
blocked off and well there's some action
to be done on the Queen side you still
have to figure out what happens if in
the future maybe ideas like b5 are
played but that's pretty much that
regarding breakthroughs in the position
so here
Knight the f1 by Magnus he sees that
night to g3 to h5 could result in this
f6 pawn becoming vulnerable sometimes in
the future
so just nice to F 1 we have Knight to a4
by Nakamura and now came to e2 we have
knight back to b2 and kink the b2 now
Knight c4 check with King to c3 also the
knight from f1 nicely defends the e3
pawn and now tonight the b8
we have Knight to b3 and now comes
Knight to a6 and here cross and decides
for this very nice
seek actress and b6 with Knight captures
and now Knight to a5 he goes after the
c6 bond and the King to d7 now defending
it but now no one is guarding the f6
pawn so now this night he jumps to g3 he
wants to come to h5 and pick up the f6
pawn so King to c7 and now Knights to h5
the King made room for the night on d7
so 97 guarding the f6 pawn and now
Knight back to b3 preparing to put this
night on this very nice c5 outpost so
King to d8 now nakamura wants to shift
the King over to defend the f6 pawn and
now Knight to c5 again offering some
trades here and if you capture here you
just allow cross and scheme to march of
the board so not really what you want to
do so--here night 8 to be 8 by nakamura
but now for calls and finds the only
breakthrough that exists on the board
and that is b5 this is how we make
progress you cleared the be 4 square for
your king and you will recapture the
pawn later as the two knights are unable
to defend the pawn
so see captors and King to be for now
going after the b5 pawn Knight to c6
check with King captures and now Knights
the a7 check we have King the a6 by
Magnus and mount Knight captures and c5
with check and here Magnus captures on
a7 and this is actually not not the best
the capturing an a7 results only in the
draw
unfortunately for Magnus however D
captures on c5 is the correct way to go
but it's it's of course a rapid game and
you don't have a lot of time to
calculate so Magnus captured here but
now he car is the one who makes a wrong
turn
instead of knights the d3 he goes Knight
to b3 and Knight to b3 does make sense
you wanna go Knight b3 you want to
capture this pawn here and after captors
start pushing you're a pawn
however he can't play and while this is
not the best 93 is hard hard to
calculate because after Knight captures
and f6 the point is you have Knight f4
you defend this point and attack this
one and once white makes a move now you
kick back the night and you kind of
don't want to go to h5 it's very sad
square now for the White Knight black
will always be able to recapture here on
h3 you're defending this point and it
shouldn't be more than a draw so
probably we would see a repetition here
if King a nice checking here night here
here and a nice repetition
however he car went for King tonight the
b3 and now it's a bit different we have
King to b6 by Magnus and now King 37 you
cannot go for this right away because if
the characters captures and you start
pushing Knight g3 covers D 2 square so
there's no nothing happening here
so King d7 by Hikaru but now Knight
captures on f6 would check of course you
don't you have to capture we cannot call
out the King to defend it King to d6 now
98 check King to d7 in the Knights to c7
now going after this pawn but also now
you have a past F pawn that black has to
worry about and here there really is no
good move for for Nakamura so he tried
one last one last try Knight captures on
d4 but Magnus of course just recapture
that and said that there is nothing for
for black did to do here and it was in
his position our move
56 that Nakamura resigned the game
problem is that you have a check and
that's why you you will reach it upon
for example a 3/3 you have a knight to
a6 and which will be followed by Knight
to c5 check and it doesn't matter if you
move the King you still get night c5 and
then you jammed the knight to d3 which
covers d1 square so here just this check
you move the King and now tonight's the
night the d3 reaches a 1 and the Magnus
is just up a knight and of course
completely winning so he car notice this
after he captures on d4 and he resigned
here so this is game 3 of their match in
the Magnus cross and Invitational Magnus
is now leading two to one and we'll see
what happens in the next game Hikaru
must win on demand if he wants to take
the match into Armageddon and don't
worry about the other match up being
versus Alireza I will of course show
those games as well so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it there was a lot
of horsing around but you know it's not
never simple as you can see here I would
like to thank Epirus off Andres
Mikhailovsky Dominic Robson on Taronga
tani tantra and the key and Piatt for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video sierra
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day